Josh hey there yeah are you doing buddy
I'm doing okay where are you right now
I am I pulled over on the side of the
road after dropping my son off and let
me talk a little football with you guys
so I turned on the radio a little early
and I heard my name and my son is like
of course the next question was what's a
hot guy what is hot guy what does that
mean I go what are you what do you think
it means I it's a superhero I think your
son needs to just look in the mirror and
then he'll know what hot guy is believe
now you are you're in transformers I
mean you are kind of a superhero you
just didn't did you tell him you didn't
get drafted in the hot guy draft not so
he doesn't think of me as superhero no
no okay all right what's good have you
on the Christmas card was great picture
of you and Axl so thank you for sending
that my daughter's always get a big kick
out of that they go did we get the do
mail credit got Christmas card and so
thank you for sending that guy's great
yeah we're all good you know how nervous
are you with this game of the Vikings in
San Francisco I'm more excited than
anything you know I was in the Laurel as
last week for the game and I was nervous
about that because you know we were big
underdogs but they came out you know the
Vikings in my opinion they can beat
anybody if they play like that you know
if Cousins is playing well the defense
is flying around and you know not gonna
quarterback off your spot there's a
chance so I feel good I feel excited I
know that we're gonna be underdogs again
but you know it's why the clinic games
Dan are you going to the game I am I'm
leaving here in about two hours I'm
gonna meet my dad nice oh my girl and
her dad are all gone oh okay so you're
gonna be wait you buried the lede your
girl whoa
Josh Duhamel in love question mark go do
you wanna give me a details those things
that I wish said and as I was saying
that if I was going to compare your new
girlfriend to a quarterback my new
girlfriend to a quarterback Patrick
mahomes oh okay young versatile she she
she can throw the deep she's
ambidextrous yeah it's a good that's
good that's good you got a new woman in
your life that's good very happy for you
you know you need a break yeah my dad's
big Vikings fan so it all works out do
you love her more than you love the
Vikings oh god of course I do
yeah of course I do of course you love
her more than you do the bike okay
that's the right that's the right this
memory remember when you called me after
the Vikings lost in the playoffs like
you were in the parking lot weren't you
you were leaving they just against the
one against the Seahawks and that
freezing yes yes yes that's what it was
yeah yeah do I remember that yeah I just
remember you were you were like you were
so despondent I don't even know if you
knew what you were doing or saying
you're just you were just so so bummed
out when you're gone you know how do you
miss him I'll know you'll go oh I'll
never forget this stuff like that the
silence walking out of that saying stay
notice talking it was freezing all you
heard was the shuffling of snow boots I
mean that face and so when we're leaving
the stadium in New Orleans this past
weekend I stopped
you know they were like it was kind of
the same thing they were not expecting
to get beat like that and there's just
this despondent depressed you know
confused feeling that these defendants
New Orleans had and you know god bless
them they were really cold unlike the
ones in Philadelphia a couple years ago
they were terrible that's a tough place
it was yeah Philly times are tough no
doubt but you know it was so we're all
excited but we also knew what it felt
like to be in their shoes so anyway
we're hoping for a win this week how
much confidence you have in Kirk because
ins
well if Kirk shows up and plays pissed
off he's much better in my opinion I
mean it I'd like to Kirk Dooley had like
midway through the season where you know
he was he was getting a lot of a lot of
I don't know what do you want to call it
from you know Thielen and digs everybody
else you know they were they were kind
of turning on him and that's when he
kind of started to let him loosen up
playing so safe and when he plays like
that I think he's great but when he
tries to play within this little thing
and doesn't doesn't I don't know move
around the pocket or try to make things
happen outside the play he just is
average but he can also be great and he
was great last week that's what I'm
hoping plays this week he's Josh Duhamel
he's an actor Vikings fan he's the face
of North Dakota tourism and he's in love
and he'll be at the game with the 49ers
by the way you want to date Daytime Emmy
right I did I did that was a Outstanding
Supporting Actor in a Drama Series on
All My Children
where is your Emmy it's sitting on my
shelf at home okay
because I got I got a few of them in
here where are your numerous awards that
I was just listening to they're all over
the place in fact that's why I built a
new man cave I just didn't have enough
space for all these awards it's it's not
a man cave it's called a mantle it's
just it's just where you put all your
awards here but so so many awards here
if I said you could have a Golden Globe
or the Vikings go
the Super Bowl I'm taking the golden
club all day at least you're honest
unlike you I don't feel any guilt you
know being away from the sound this well
safe travels up there and if you want to
call me you know if the bike win or lose
you can call me from the parking lot if
you want to you're picking because
you're on the line I'll take the biking
something come on seriously do you think
you think we got a shot yes yes yes we
beat the Niners you got to be smart and
I think if you put pressure if you put
pressure on drop elope because we
haven't seen him in this situation and
you don't have to bring any extra help
you have four guys and you put pressure
on him cook is able to run the ball
successfully and you get a couple of
plays from Kirk Cousins then you can win
that game yeah I agree
hey safe travels and happier in love and
we'll talk to you soon
that's Josh Duhamel yeah I think we
broke some news there I think I don't
know who the girlfriend is but maybe we
need to Google something say check his
Twitter or something yes he checked and
this is gonna surprise you but she's hot
she's stunning I saw that coming what a
shocker for more Dan Patrick show tune
in to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]